I'm just welcoming you to the 2019 Adam
and an Avery Perry lecture and this
lecture is in the memory of Adam Perry
and Perry who died tragically in 1971 in
an accident when they were vacationing
in France
Adam was it was the head of the classics
department here he was a distinguished
cross assist remembered I think for his
studies one thing of editing his
father's Milman Perry's work and making
them much more coherent and his works on
Homer and at the same time he was best
known for those of us who work on Virgil
for his famous essay the two voices of
Virgil's Aeneid
and Emory Perry was also a classicist
she was associate professor at the
University of Massachusetts when she
died and was a well-known scholar at
that point of Lucretius she also was one
of the authors of the textbook with
which I learned Latin Aeneas to Augustus
so she was a distinguished class assist
their portraits are right there there
moralized in this in this library and
this library is partly based on their
their original collection this lecture
is sponsored by the comparative
literature department and by the
classics department and it's made
possible by a generous gift of Gilbert s
Lawal who was a professor of classics at
the University of Massachusetts our
speaker today is Emily Wilson who was a
product of the classics and comparative
literature departments here at Yale and
I'm going to
as opposed to an introducer for you
thank you so since this is our this is
our flagship literature comparative and
classical lecture this year you get two
introductions there are seats down there
are not seats but there are places to
put yourself down on the floor there's a
floor so we are we are thrilled I think
this is not the first time that Emily
has been here in the last 12 months
I came about 18 months ago okay about 18
months ago but we are thrilled to have
Emily Wilson here she is a professor of
classics and comparative literature at
the University of Pennsylvania and she I
think until quite recently was well
known for her fascinating work on death
on Sophocles Socrates Milton and other
dead dudes movie and she started
translating as early as 2010 when she
brought out six tragedies of Seneca with
with Oxford most recently before the
explosion
she wrote a life of Seneca and she's
very interested in the kind of interplay
between poetics and literary theory
literature and philosophy and
translation which she has now turned to
so you will all know her translation of
Homer's Odyssey which has made such an
impression that Yale is actually using
it for DES now I don't know what they've
done with the venerable who were they
using before was it Fitzgerald
it was fagles
she has plans to do the Iliad and also
to write a monograph on the way she
translates and what the stakes are in
translating and I'm hoping very much
that she will talk a little bit about
that tonight so I'd like you to welcome
Emily Wilson please translating the
classics again
[Applause]
thank you so much drivel for being here
and I'm sorry that many of you are very
uncomfortable it's a huge honor to be
here both to be speaking in memory of
the Powys process extra honor to be
speaking memory the parries which I'm
talking partly about Homer it's also it
feels particularly resonant to be coming
back to this room after something like
20 years and in a way this is a kind of
Ithaca and so I'm going to talk
primarily about my approach to
translating the Odyssey and whatever
theoretical and analytical and
hermeneutic and literary questions that
that project raised for me and then in
the final section of the talk I'm going
to try and talk more broadly about the
field of translations from ancient Greek
and Latin and the ways that I think
there might be issues in that field and
possible directions that we might change
it's hard to talk about translation in
the abstract I think toleration Theory
is very interesting but I also think it
can be very much divorced from the daily
or word by word practice praxis so I
want to start by reading a relatively
long chunk from my translation of the
Odyssey just to give you an idea about
what I did in that project I'm gonna
read the great passage from book 19 when
it is seus is stolen disguised as a
homeless or beggar and still hasn't
revealed himself to Penelope his wife so
this is right after the famous scene
where Yura Claire the old nurse slave
woman has recognized Odysseus by
watching his feet and touching the scar
on his leg and he's half bottled her to
try and shut her up so she doesn't give
the game away too soon so I'm gonna skip
here Eclair
and start when husband and wife still
not fully in who aren't yet known to
each other they're talking to each other
and I try and put on silly voices just
to show that part of one of my points
about translating the Parliament by the
ones things one of the things I want to
emphasize today is how I very much
wanted to bring out how this is a
proteome attic poem which has multiple
different voices multiple different
perspectives I apologize for my bad
acting and our voice for Penelope that
supposed to be kind of like the Queen
because who emphasized how elite years
and carefully Penelope spoke to him
stranger I have one small question I
want to ask you it will soon be time to
lie down comfortably at least for those
who can enjoy sweet sleep no matter what
but I have been afflicted by some God
with pain beyond all measure in the day
I concentrate on my work and my woman's
despite my constant grief but when night
comes and everybody goes to sleep
I like crying and bed and overwhelmed by
pain worries and sorrows crowd into my
heart has when the daughter of Pandaria
s-- the pale grade nightingale sings
beautifully when spring has come and
sits among the leaves the crowd the
trees and warbles up and down a symphony
of sound in mourning for her son by
zebus darling italy's whom she herself
has killed in ignorance with bronze just
so my mind pulls two directions should I
stay here beside my son and keep things
all the same by property where slave
girls and my great house to show respect
towards my husband's bed and what the
people say or should I marry one of them
whichever is best of all the suitors and
can bring most presents when my son was
immature and young I could have leave my
husband's house he would have left me
now that he is big and all grown up he
urges me to go he is concerned that they
are eating up his property now how do
you interpret this dream of mine I
dreamed I just realize I have some geese
so I suppose to be looking at the geese
I dreamed the twenty geese came from the
river to my house
and they were eating grain and I was
glad to see them then a huge Eagle with
a pointed beak swooped from the Mountain
Brook Phoenix and killed them I wept and
wailed inside the dream the women
gathered around me and I cried because
the Eagle killed my geese then he came
back and sitting on the jutting roof
beam spoken human language to restrain
my grief Penelope
great Queen cheer up this is no dream it
will come true it is a vision the gisa
suitors
I was once an eagle but now I am her
husband I have come back home to put a
cruel end to them then I woke up looked
round and saw the geese still eating
grain beside the trough as they had done
before
Odysseus well known for his intelligence
said my dear woman there is no way to
rest another meaning out of the dream
Odysseus himself said how he will
fulfill it
it means ruin for all the suitors no one
can protect them now from death but
shrewd Penelope said stranger dreams are
confusing and not all come true so I
wanted to read a longer passage so you
could hear some something of what my
translation is like and also of course I
wanted to use regular meter partly as a
way of inviting reading out loud so I
chose to use regular I am but pentameter
all the way through with quite a lot of
alliteration and as much attention to
the sound of words as I could muster I
did a lot of reading out loud while I
was working on it both of the original
and of my drafts in progress I think
this fabulous passage fabulous in the
original illustrates one of the most
important features of the original poem
and one that I thought constantly about
as a translator the way that his
proteges matic it has different voices
different perspectives different points
of view I love how we're never told
exactly why Penelope is crying in the
dream
I love the truthfulness of this portrait
of a radically unequal marriage in which
Odysseus does his mansplaining of the
dream to her and we never get from the
narrator what exactly is he missing that
we had this resonant absence in terms of
her meaning of her marriage his meaning
of his marriage how we're shown that
those things are different and we don't
have it spelled out that do you get it
that they're actually talking across
each other I also love how console T in
Homer an illustration in this passage is
the wonderful description of the
nightingale that the drop the drama and
the vivid psychology and deep psychology
combines with detailed description of
the material and natural and man-made
walls I think a translator of this
multi-layered poem ideally should her
should respond to all the ferried moods
voices and perspectives and of course
it's not actually possible to do
everything but I'm just gonna talk a
little bit more about how what I was
trying to do I was asked to consider
translating the Odyssey by an editor at
Norton Pete Simon whom I'd got to know
through working on the anthology of bold
literature I was excited to be asked
because I've always loved this poem this
is me when I was 8 and he was the
turning point of my life but I got to
play Athena in the school play I got to
make my own tin foil helmet it was the
first time I was exposed to the story of
the Odyssey and I made me think maybe 10
turn me on to Greek myths in general and
made me realize yes whenever I get the
chance I'm going to learn Latin and
Greek and become a classicist
and of course in my way of weeding the
Odyssey now is not identical with the
way that I encountered the story when I
was 8 and I think one of the things
that's so exciting about the Odyssey is
how it can speak differently to the same
person at different ages different
periods your life I love how it's this
infinitely rich narrative about time and
identity whether we can actually be the
same person after 40 years as am i the
same person as her I don't know and also
about how to deal with people who aren't
like us how do communities get formed
about home identity growing up grief
imagination recognition alienation
but of course loving the Odyssey and
wanted to keep on rereading it in Greek
it's totally different from thinking
it's worthwhile to add the huge mountain
of English translations of Homer that
already existed and just as an
illustration of the fact that the pace
has been picking up it's not that
there's been a steady stream of English
translations of Homer
they've been something two or maybe
three published since my translation
there's a huge number of them so why do
yet another one
I felt that I actually needed to have an
answer to that I shouldn't do it just
because somebody asked me to do it I
could have gone on reading The Odyssey
without bothering anyone with a new
translation I could have written a
monograph about it why do yet another
translation um so but I did to try and
figure out whether I ought to do another
translation was we read book 9 in Greek
very slowly and then read something like
a dozen English translations to try and
figure out whether I felt that any of
them was already doing exactly what I
would do if I was creating a new one and
I also thought back to my various
experiences of teaching the poem
especially of teaching The Wandering
books of the Odyssey and thinking about
in what ways were various translations
that I'd used either adequate or
inadequate to bring out what I would
what I would want to bring out of what
the original was doing and in doing that
exercise I realized in fact I thought I
could do something that was
significantly different and it would
work in the classroom in a very
different way as well as work
differently for the volge
for the voluntary reader and then after
that I started working it and I didn't
look at other translations for the next
five years to try and make sure that I
wasn't constantly second-guessing myself
by figuring out should I copy what he
did almost surely not copy what he did
but then since publishing my translation
in 2000 at the end of 2017 I have done
some looking back to compare with other
translators and that's always a
fascinating exercise so what motivated
me to take on the project was one of the
big motivations at the start and then
constantly throughout was to do with
literary form as you probably all know
the Odyssey is composed in ductility
hexameter tactile is a finger long short
short
samatha is six and ramai NEP moosa
pollute drop on host mallepalli it's six
beats like that
all the way through there's no line
where it suddenly doesn't scan or it
suddenly lapses into a free verse for a
little while
whereas many english translations are
not like that in any way so there's a
real question about what kind of poetic
form should you use there are a whole
lot of prose translations which of
course aren't echoing the fact of having
having rhythm in anyway another possible
way to do it is to try to use either
hexameter or something like hexameter in
english so this is the beginning of
three different translations there's the
ladder more translation which isn't
actually in hexameter but if you squeeze
your eyes together and don't really read
out loud it looks like it could be hex
outer because it's long lines there
Rodney Merrill versions of both the
Iliad and the Odyssey are in hexameter
so tell me muse of the man versatile and
resourceful who wondered and I think you
can see even from the first two lines
there's quite a big cost that's paid for
using this Elya meter in English so I
knew from the start I didn't want to do
prose I also didn't want to do the way
that is the most common among quote
unquote first translations which is kind
of like stack prose or free verse
so most so most of the ones that people
usually read are don't have a regular
meter sing in me Muse and through me
tell the story
sing to me of the man use the man of
twists and turns
speak memory or speaking a cup never
calls of this cunning hero so you
consider you can hear well already that
they did no not regularly rhythmical
metrical and you can also see for those
of you who can see their board that I
underlined a few phrases which seemed to
me to be echoing one translation in the
next which is also a kind of signal that
a lot of translators are very much
informed by the translations that have
gone before so it's not necessary to
translate that verb a person as
plundered but they all do it's not
necessary to have this
sheesh a phrase Toman again and yet it's
it's repeated so I knew from the start
that what I wanted to do was do a
regular iambic pentameter version
because I wanted to try and think about
what is the equivalent of dr. kate
saratov which is the normal meter for
narrative poetry in archaic Greece
within the Anglophone poetic tradition
it's obviously ambach pentameter
it's obviously not hexameter i wanted to
be paying homage to the long tradition
of english metrical poetry as well as to
to homeless traditions i also chose to
to make my translation the same number
of lines as the original which i
constantly kicked myself for because it
was very difficult to from hexameters
into pentameters in fact when i and i'd
be constantly trying to compress in
various ways and I felt that in fact
when I did that which I was constantly
doing it had certain good effects that
it was actually helpful in bringing out
the simplicity of homers syntax that I
was constantly having to think about is
the Obon Wade so I've said what I think
this says in a rhythm but I'm one line
too long I need to go back and think
about whether there were elements where
I'm actually adding words which don't
need to get added and so in general I
think translations tend to be longer
than originals this is true not just of
Homer but of translations in general
because one's constantly thinking this
word doesn't have any exact equivalent
in my language they could mean a hundred
different things so I'm gonna put down
three different things and cover all my
bases and then you end up with a
translation which is much much longer
and a lot of translations of both of
Homer and of everything do that
and I liked the line for line thing and
it was constantly forcing myself I was
costly forcing myself not to be
expansive I also felt that there was a
benefit to not not adding in extra extra
words extra syllables in that it kept
the rapidity of Homer one of the famous
four qualities of of Homeric verse
according to Matthew Arnold is rapidity
and I felt in looking at multiple
english translations that a lot of them
didn't have that though they didn't have
that quick now
to pace where you actually don't have
time to get bored you actually want to
get it on to the next line because
you're constantly being propelled
forward in the story forward and in the
scene more generally and I guess this is
well I guess this is a bigger a bigger
tendency was about simplifying the poems
narrative mode this is looking back to
what I was saying earlier about the
depiction of the marriage of Odysseus
and Penelope but it's much broader than
that but this is a poem which does have
more than one point of view I felt in
looking at other translations that there
was a tendency to simplify the narrative
perspectives to treat the poem as if it
was more often than I think it is
looking through Odysseus his eyes and
also a tendency to to simplify the moral
and psychological world of Homer by
suggesting there's something sort of
primary about Odysseus experience which
again I'm not sure the original does I
wants to bring out the multiplicity of
voices rather than reducing them all
Yura Clare has one experience of her
owners homecoming Odysseus has another
Penelope's experience of her greet her
geese are not the same as the way that
it is yes explains the bees I was
constantly thinking in quasi novelistic
way about the motivations and voice of
every character and in that process I
was surprised to discover how well that
seemed to work that in fact the Homeric
characters will eat our fully alive even
those that I have thought at the start
of the project might be kind of boring
to write like all the old windbag Nestor
turned out to be really fun to try and
recreate in general I want to convey
something of a musicality clarity
vividness emotional psychological depth
range Beauty narrative drive that seemed
to me essential elements in Homer I also
wanted to write as well as I possibly
could on the principle that a great poem
shouldn't be turned into a horrible one
an issue that arises for every
translator of homer is what to do about
repetition and formula whatever to do by
that element of Homeric verse that the
Perry's were so good in
it's a very repetitive poem because of
course it's based on a centuries-long
oral tradition all cultures value
repetition you keep on repeating the
things that you really think are
important you're not going to remember
what your great-great-great-great
grandmother said unless you keep on
repeating those phrases well as in a
ultra literate culture like ours where a
petition tends to be a sign of whitening
laziness it tends to be a signal you can
skip now because this person hasn't
thought about it
or else it can be a signal of I'm trying
to be go to Stine get his Stein Gertrude
Stein Greta Stein and again that's not
actually what Homeric repetition is
doing now I wanted to convey some
definite sense of the this is a world
with stable repeated elements the
whirlwind oxys wyandotte sees and some
more when doubt sees the horse Lord
Nestor is going to keep on being host or
nurse Don but I didn't want to keep the
poem quite as repetitive as the original
is because I felt in going through
different experimenting with different
ways of doing that that if I repeated
too much it started to feel dead on the
page in a way that I felt the original
wasn't so in some cases I chose to
create variation within the repeated
tropes to switch up the way that
repeated epithets were translated so for
example the line about rosy-fingered
dawn one of the most famous repeated
lines in the Odyssey of course it
matters this line is in a poem about
time it's repeated something like 20
times always the same in my translation
I kept the same components dawn is
always a goddess always early on newborn
always has fingers are touching always
blooming or has flowers or roses but I
mixed up the ways those elements fit
together on the page the question of
buzz form is related to larger issues
about style I was aiming for a readable
clear register to occur the simple very
readily comprehensible syntax of Homer I
very largely avoided our key Azam's
foreign isms and high rhetoric to bring
out the simplicity clarity and speed I
know that some readers have labeled my
translation style as modernizing or
domestic sizing but I think that's not
the
whole thing about what I was doing
stylistically even beyond the fact that
most people don't talk in iambic
pentameter all the time there are other
elements of artifice so for instance I
avoided all contractions like doesn't
and don't because I wanted not necessary
to have huge numbers of vocabulary words
throw the high school reader off but I
also wanted to make sure the register
would feel a little bit different from
normal speech even beyond the fact it's
metrical but it would be not quite like
how everybody speaks even though it's
close to it
I was also conscious that Humaira Greek
is a language that nobody ever actually
spoke it's a mix of dialects from
different parts of the greek-speaking
world from different eras which of
course again is for legacy of oral
tradition it would have been really fun
to try and replicate that collage
quality by constantly using a mix of
cockney Chaucerian jazz Weejun
California Ebonics mix it all up
together and it'd be a great joy see and
experiment but nobody would have read it
and it also would have made homeless
earn much more Joycean than the original
does because I would have been a fake
tradition there was no such tradition in
English poetry so and I also knew that
if I did that it would be fun for me but
it wouldn't allow me to do anything else
about conveying this is a poem about
human emotions and you might actually
have carrot as you care about it would
have been all about the language so in I
couldn't tell you I couldn't do that and
do the other things
so instead as a sort of compromise I
thought it's a good thing if sometimes
my language is surprising it's a good
thing if sometimes it's surprising in
the direction of colloquialism sometimes
it's surprising in some other way like
Oh suffrage it's not a colloquial word
it's just a weird word and it's a great
word so I'm sometimes gonna have words
which don't feel totally neutral which
feel marked in some way just to as a nod
to the original it's not all homogeneous
linguistically so what does it mean to
translate responsibly I think on one
level is totally impossible the whole
project isn't most impossible and I
think a responsible translator is one
who knows how impossible it is
translation theorists following louis
bernucci onto am berman echoing the
theologian schema
and talked a lot about the distinction
between foreign izing and domestic
sizing translation styles and many
translation theorists defend some mode
of foreign izing I think one of the
biggest challenges is how to be truthful
to both the strangeness and the
familiarity of the text at heart and I'd
argue that the specific strategies a
translator has to is using have to be
modulated to adapt to the cultural place
of the translated text in the target
culture in the case of modern novels
like those translated by venuti there's
definitely an expectation among American
and British readers of a fluent domestic
sizing style you don't want to have to
think I read a translation of the girl
with a dragon tattoo and I can really
assess the translators qualities as a
writer and translator instead you want
to think I've read the girl with a
dragon tattoo and it was kind of
forgettable whereas in the case of Asian
issue especially ultra canonical in
Tunisia modern readers have a totally
different set of expectations they think
they think that they're going to up
front be thinking about the translation
and judging it and then they may be
expecting ancient epic just sound
bombastic and sub melt on ik archaic
Farsi maybe it should be unreadable
because that shows how all the timing it
is regardless of whether the original
actually sounded like that at any period
of antiquity I think it's also true that
within classics in particular badly
written translations are tolerated and
sometimes highly valued in that they
replicate the experience of the
struggling student in intermediate Greek
or Latin class so the pain is supposed
to be authenticating even though of
course in antiquity people liked Homer
which I think is an important fact to
actually try to think about as a
translator it should be enjoyable we're
accustomed to taking for granted a very
debatable set of binaries that
translations are either literal or loose
they're either faithful or they're
poetic those binaries rely on the false
idea that there's just one thing the
original poem means or is or does the
question for any translator isn't
whether to tell the truth or tell
acquittee lie it's a much more complex
issue about which truth
to tell but for many true facts about
any original text like this so there
could be multiple different true
portraits of a particular individual and
of course in fact one can't tell all the
truths at the same time related to what
I was saying earlier about how I knew I
couldn't tell the truth about linguistic
diversity to the max if I was also going
to try to tell the truth about
characterization one of the most
important truths I wants to tell about
the Odyssey was that it's a complex poly
vocal poem I've seen from teaching it
there's a tendency to assume it's an
old-school comic book superhero story
it's like this about the unpalatable
Western hero implicitly white or proto
white who is good because he crushes the
bad guys monsters foreigners and witty
women and understands the value of
hospitality which apparently was
important back in the day wait they're
done on the exam to hope to gain a the
story has a happy ending because the
good guy gets back with the objectified
wife and regains all his wealth and all
his slaves so it's a nice celebration of
Family Values consumerism patriarchy war
superiority of normal male white people
/ foreigners and girls and I mean I was
emphasizing stars I both loved the poem
when I was 8 and still love it now and I
wouldn't if that was the only thing I
thought the Odyssey was doing I wanted
to create a translation which was very
hard to read that way to make it clear
that the Odyssey is is a much better
poem than that there was a truthfully
complex recreation of this complex text
The Odyssey explores two central Greek
concepts both of which I think it deals
that it deals with both these central
apparently simple concepts in a complex
and nuanced way
the first is nostos of what that means
homecoming you might think home is very
straightforward it just means getting
back to the place where you used to live
of course the Odyssey presents this
ultra difficult case of homecoming
Odysseus gets back geographically
halfway through the poem that clearly is
not enough for an Oscar to be complete
it's also it's exploring what else needs
to happen beyond geography for the
homecoming to happen and it's also
exploring what costs are there to
man's homecoming for all the other
people who don't get home the majority
of characters who tried to have a
homecoming in this poem do not have one
and end up dead in what ways does
Odysseus's homecoming affect other
people including those that he abandons
and those that he kills and those that
he fails to save the central the second
we turn that central for the poem is
seniya which means the ideal
relationship between strangers guests
and hosts in this code people have a
deep obligation to take care of
strangers in need in giving and
receiving hospitality if families form
lasting friendships across great
distances of space and time it's in many
ways inspiring especially in times of
xenophobia and hostility to immigrants
but it's also tracing all the various
ways that the code fails to work the
ways it breaks down how it doesn't apply
to anyone except for elite men when
women try to travel is Helen of Troy
it's about it's a bad thing it's also
tracing the ways that Affinia can go
wrong and then can lead to war can lead
to violence masood azhar like bad gusts
invading Odysseus's home without asking
and Odysseus is the worst kind of host
the original poem to me is compelling
because of the nuanced and complicated
nests of its presentation of its own
core values and how deeply it lets us
inside the perspective of so many
different different people a concrete
example of how translations can either
bring out or erase diversity of those
perspectives I think it's about whether
or not the slaves that well staged as
being slaves it's very common in fact
the majority way of translating Tamar
was Tamara in the Odyssey including in
translations that came out after mine is
to render them as handmade or maid or
servant which i think is - is not just
because of course the word slave has
different connotations about how evil
slavery is but has made also has
different connotations which are very
misleading and I think much more
misleading I think there's a systemic
blindness in wanting Odysseus not to be
presented as a slave owner because that
means that it's clear he's not
necessarily a good guy and I think
that's to do with a general trend
towards simplifying the poems social
world and ethical
concepts so he's going to read the
beginning of my translation just to
emphasize how even in the first few
lines the poem the poem is highlighting
not just the complicated homecoming of
one man but also the terrible loss of
life in loss of homecoming experienced
by the vast majority of other human
characters tell me about a complicated
man
muse tell me how he wandered and was
lost when he had wrecked the holy town
of Troy and where he went and who he met
the pain he suffered on the sea and how
he worked to save his life and bring his
men back home he failed and for their
own mistakes they died they at the Sun
God's cattle and the God kept them from
home now
goddess Charlotte Zeus tell the old
story for our modern times I can comment
on that passage and what I did with it
but I maybe I'll leave that for Q&A I
have lots to say about it if you have
questions since publishing my
translation I looked closely at a few
passages of mine next to other
translations and that exercise has made
me even more aware of what a world of
difference in interpretation and
characterization as well as style can
lie in the details of word choice I've
realized that there were things that I
didn't realize weren't going to be end
up being more choices if he looks at
them next to other translations but I
now realize that's different from what
other people chose to do so for instance
many translations present Calypso the
goddess with whom Odysseus spends seven
years as a historical nymphomaniac which
i think is about being misled by the
false friend of nymph that's means a
different thing in ancient Greek from
what it means in contemporary English
culture I think the three texts
presenter is dignified powerful kind of
scarily powerful emotionally intelligent
and her advice to sangha is a feeling
that we can but at least while she's
talking empathize with similarly many
modern translations seem to make
Polyphemus the Cyclops into quote a
monster or a savage which i think is in
keeping with modern colonial prejudice
against native peoples whereas the Greek
texts
which of course was also produced in a
context of diaspora and colonialism
defines this terrifying cannibal as
definitely a human being and anthropos
and allows for at least some degree of
sympathy for the person whose home is
invaded and whose eye is mutilated so
then I'm gonna talk in a love of more
detail in about this passage from book
22 after Odysseus gets home he is in
disguised for several books as the old
beggar and then eventually reveals
himself to Telemachus and to and to
slaves who helped out with the massacre
and they Massacre the suitors and then
get the slaves to clean up all the human
trash by taking the corpses outside and
scrubbing the blood and gore from their
lovely floors and lovely tables so it's
all going to look nice and be fully
owned by Odysseus of course part of the
the process of cleanup is to do with
making sure that the space fully belongs
to him again
that means eradicating the marks of
earlier owners and and then after that
that process the cleaning ladies
themselves have to be cleansed by being
murdered and Odysseus tells Telemachus
that the the twelve women who've been
sleeping with or he says earlier in the
book raped by the suitors must be hacked
to death with sores Telemachus who's
been kind of a dopey manchild up to this
point for the first time seems to have
an idea of his own and his idea is that
he shouldn't use a sword instead he
should hang them so in looking at
different translations of this passage
I've realized that um I read the passage
as having more than one point of view
that he doesn't just have the point of
view of them of the murderer I think
some quite a lot of translations shapes
a narrative so it seems as if we're
constantly looking through the eyes of
Telemachus that we're seeing his own
self justification for what he does so
notice that for people who can see the
Greek I've underlined what Telemachus
says just before he kills the twelve
women which I just noticed that it
doesn't have a term of abuse he doesn't
actually
use any kind of mound to slur them he
calls them the women who slept beside
the suitors so I'm just going to fly
three or four different elements of
translation choice so Telemachus is
usually called pepper numinous it's his
standard epithet purp numerous it's just
something or other to do with cognition
he's had some kind of thought in his
mind it was a good thought does he have
a great idea at this moment a clearly a
translator has some leeway about whether
you present it as he's thoughtful in a
good way or is he thoughtful in a way
that might not necessarily be great when
he's doing this so many translators seem
to add to use words to translate that
that suggests he's definitely positive
at this moment though for his sagacious
he's done he's cool-headed he's not
acting on impulse
he's really thought about it so it must
be okay and then when it went in Lemcke
speaks that's when we get the clearest
glimpse of what is his motivation why is
she killing them also why is he killing
them with a rope rather than the sword
that his dad said he should use it seems
to me that the reason he's killing them
with it with the rope and killing them
at all is because he's they make him
feel ashamed that they're a marker of
the disempowerment of his life in the
years when the suitors were dominating
the house they're a reminder that he
wasn't the boss of the household many
translators don't seem to read it that
way and instead they present it that
he's killing them because they are
socially evil and it's because of their
sexual crimes that they have to die
which i think is a very different
interpretation and translators very
often get that interpretation by adding
in terms of abuse which aren't in the
Greek so for instance we have these
creatures we have beasts trolls [ __ ]
[ __ ] suitors [ __ ] suitors [ __ ] and
then a common scholarly discourse has to
do with the main thing to say about this
passage is how big but the Rope have to
be shalt ages of course also can control
how you read by the notes and by the
other apparatus as well and then so
there's this wonderful simile
comparing the women to birds that are
caught in a trap and it seems to me that
that simile can be read one of two or
maybe both of two very very different
ways it can work to dehumanize them it
can work to suggest this is just like
killing a chicken it's fine they're not
real human beings because they're like
birds or it can work to show that they
have their own motivation they have
their own perspective it suggests that
they also wanted a nostos they wants to
go home and go to bed in the Greek they
the place that their boards are going
back to is an illness it's a word that
can be used to human habitations as well
as those nests so the simile the
language of the simile is not
necessarily dehumanizing even the birds
maybe it's humanizing the birds rather
than dehumanizing the women but just
notice how a lot of translations in my
opinion pushed the simile towards
dehumanization by using language which
seems to trivialize the experience of
birds like cozy must grizzly bear which
is kind of physical and then a final
detail with the touch on is the horrible
moment at the end when the woman's feet
move just for a little while and then
they stop moving forever and it's
striking to me that several translators
seem to present the movement of the feet
as all part of this criminal behavior
they've united in life or this sexually
wrong behavior of life they're party
girls and therefore they're still
dancing so that shows what happens to
particles or they kicked up heels for a
while not for long
and then the Narmada one seems to
suggest they're still kind of birds even
when they're dying so follows through
with the dehumanizing and I didn't know
did I I personally don't think that the
narrator is necessarily either
dehumanizing or presenting them as
criminals
I think the narrator has a sense of deep
pity for those who are dying something's
gonna be my version of that scene
Telemachus then took initiative
insisting I refused to grant these girls
a clean death since they put down shame
on me and mother when they lay beside
the suitors and that here and a piece of
sailors rope round the Rotunda and round
the mighty pillar stretched up so
I know foot could touch the ground as
doves or Russia's spread their wings to
fly home to their nests but someone set
a trap they crashed into a net a bitter
bedtime just throw the girls their heads
all in the world was strung up with the
noose around their necks to make their
death in agony they gasped feet
wrenching for a while but not for long
so I gots to bring out how I think
though their women are in a way like
Odysseus himself they want to get home
and go to bed they want a nostos so I've
emphasized I'm gonna move on to the
final section of my talk I've emphasized
how in my account of how I'd approach
translating the Odyssey they wants to
take seriously the fluid narrative
perspective of the poem the ways that
this single epic includes multiple
voices multiple genuinely different
perspectives on the narrative I think a
responsible translator should inhabit
several different voices different
worlds I mean it's also true of moving
from one text to another
I very much didn't want my translation
of the Odyssey to sound exactly the same
as my earlier translations of Seneca or
to have Seneca sound the same as your
bodies or have your buddies sound the
same as Sophocles I don't have any I'm
not going to talk in any detail about
what that meant in every case the main
thing I just want to emphasize is that
there's a limit to how much you can talk
about translation in the abstract
well now I'm working on my translation
of the Iliad and I've gone through many
different sand wrestling's with isn't
even gonna be in pentameter I don't know
I definitely don't want it to sound
exactly the same as my Odyssey the whole
mood of the poem is totally different so
I'm just going to read my current draft
at the beginning but I'm sure I'm going
to tinker with it constantly for the
next five years
goddess sing of the cataclysmic rage of
peeli assist an Achilles cause of so
much suffering for the Greeks has sent
many strong souls to Hades making men a
feast for birds and prey for dogs the
plan of Zeus was moving to its end
beginning when those two argued First
Lord Agamemnon and glorious Achilles
so I'm conscious in just moving from the
Odyssey to the Iliad that it's a much
more intensely claustrophobic poem and
it's going to take me a long time to get
to the white atmosphere so just in the
last few minutes I wanted to talk a
little bit more broadly because I wasn't
as advertised as talking about
translating the classics not just the
Odyssey so I would do some general marks
at the end so I guess I wanted to just
to note the extraordinary lack of both
social and literary diversity in this
field which i think is a weird thing
that we should actually be talking about
classics in general especially literary
classics is far less male-dominated than
it used to be there are a lot of female
classicists there are huge numbers of
female literary translators in general
the fields of interpretation and
translation they're female dominated not
male-dominated there are lots of female
translators of classical texts into
other languages such as French and
Italian so why does the Anglophone
classical tradition have a problem with
diversity why is it that I was
apparently the first woman to publish a
translation of the Aussie and English
which I think is part of a huge larger
pattern it's not really about me
I think the first type of structural
cause is to do with a failure of
Anglophone institutions including the
Academy the press the publishing
industry to support and nurture
potential translators in general
translation tends to be undervalued in
the elite academy a translation usually
doesn't get you tenure or promotion at
the elite colleges or universities their
particular problematic ways that
translation is viewed in the Anglophone
Academy affect classical translation far
more than literary translation in
general because of course the living
people who are bilingual in living
languages but that's not the case for
ancient Greek and Latin so we do there
are in order to have advanced knowledge
of ancient Greek and Latin you've
usually gone through a ph.d program so
then they cultural biases of PhD
granting institutions tend to affect
what you think you can do in your career
I think that this situation also helps
explain why a significant number of the
most prominent people who are
publishing literary translations of
classical texts now including women
don't have an academic appointment like
Elisha Stallings Sarah wooden pamela
mensch or many many classical
translators are in english awaiting
programs not in classics i think this is
also part of why so many greco-roman
translations are published by very old
people as a as a retirement project in
general structures to make things
difficult for everyone
tend to make them extra difficult for
less privileged members of the group
women are still statistically less
likely to get 10 years and men women are
more statistically likely to spend hours
and hours on admin and child care and
elder care and housework and so there
may be extra pressure to do the quote
unquote white kind of publishing which
probably doesn't mean the translation
you might think then that then america
old lady classicist will be just as
likely to publish translations in
retirement as an emeritus old gentleman
classicist but right now this doesn't
seem to happen nearly as much from what
i can see so i think there are other
kinds of explanations that we need i
think it's where we run into other kinds
of institutional bias i think there was
probably a big gap in how often do
publishing editors approach young women
as opposed to men I also think the
particular biases of reviewers teachers
readers scholars and students can enable
unexamined gender biases on the part of
any trouble the translators of any
gender for example by failing to comment
where the translations are thoughtful
about how to translate terms for rape or
whether translators think about how to
translate gender-neutral terms like
anthropos or homo and Latin whether the
translator treats female characters with
less empathy from the original does I
think
reviewers also tend to treat male and
female translators different differently
depending on the canonicity of the text
being translated so Pamela menses
Plutarch was not marketed as a women's
translation even though presumably she
was a woman whereas my Odyssey
translation was very much marketed as by
a woman so he was sent almost
exclusively to female reviewers who
almost all made the piece almost
entirely about my gender identity
interviewers ad nauseum asked me about
my supposedly special interest in female
characters so I've gone back to read
interviews with male translators of the
unseen like bagels standing on board Oh
Robert Fitzgerald they were never asked
about their unique masculine point of
view instead of their special interest
in male characters instead they got to
talk about poetics so I think it's
pressure on women women writers as well
as women translators to represent the
entire female perspective so that you
don't have to read more than one woman
writer because you've got it all done
the other main structural causes and
more specific classics and I think
helped explain why the gender gap is so
much greater for classics than for other
areas of literary translation and so
much greater in the Anglophone world
than in other traditions I think it's
partly about the elite white male
history of the discipline generally I
think it's also about endemic denial
within anglophone classics about the
fundamentally interpretive nature of
literary translation quote unquote
translation means something very
distinctive with in classics pedagogy
students know that they aren't learning
to translate flow bar in intermediate
French class but in intermediate Lavin
class they think they're translating
Virgil the pedagogy encourages a
instrumental vision of translation is
the tool for comprehension of a
fundamentally incomprehensible original
as if it's a crossword puzzle and your
translation is solution that you write
in the boxes and of course that enables
the idea that clunky badly written
translations including those that might
impose their translator Zone on critical
social biases or just what it means and
if you think that there's only one right
answer it doesn't matter who saw the two
plus two is four so that's I think how
part of how we get to a situation by the
work of elderly white men is seen as
simply conveying what the original says
even if there is in fact of course an
interpretation in every translation I
think the obvious next question to ask
the obvious next question to ask is
whether the status quo is a problem and
if so why
what difference would it make if there
was more social diversity would that
also imply more literary diversity I
think there's a partly separate
questions I would like more literary
diversity and more social diversity but
they might might be interconnected we're
having more women translators guarantee
a more female away from feminist
perspective on all these male k-z texts
where the dead white dudes Sohrabuddin
told me last year that women are just
really good at translation and I think
there's a disproportionate number of
good female translators in classics
right now because of the structural
inequalities not because women are
innately better I think this is part of
a general tendency by which women's work
is read primarily through the lens of
gender even if that isn't at the
forefront of the work I think you look
at multiple translations of the Odyssey
by women if you read for instance and
Dasia is French translation and Rose ons
in s T's Italian translation of read
little bits of them even I don't think
there's any common factor that's visible
on the page Carolina Thunder shall her
to hurt was the first woman to translate
the of the Iliad into English and I
don't think it has anything in common
but the way I approached translator
Miura see I do so I think it's poison
those things are not necessarily
interconnected I dream of the day just
for social justice when there will be
just as many terrible badly written
clunky sloppy thoughtless lazy classical
translations by women in English as
there already are by men but I also
think that the greater social diversity
might sometimes go in hand with great
bright of stylistic and hermeneutic
diversity if you're an elderly white man
or your peers are elderly white men you
might be less likely to question what
you're doing in a deeply critical way I
think if we're really going to go on
adding to the huge pile of read
translations of classical texts that
have already been translated gazillions
of times already we really do need more
new voices and more new perspectives and
more critical thinking about what
translation is and the different ways we
might do it translation is at the
forefront of the obnoxiously named
outreach in the field of classics
and that's of course one of the reasons
why it's so often undervalued
classicists including classical
translators are often totally uninformed
about translation theory and uncritical
about their practices we don't recognize
the kind of hermeneutic and creative
labor that ought to go into translation
work so we either don't do it at all
don't think about it or if we do do it
we do it horribly I think we need more
better more diverse translations from a
far wider range of both social and
literary perspectives and a more vibrant
conversation about the theory and
practice of translation to keep on
remapping the ever-changing imaginative
cultural geography that divides us from
antiquity
[Applause]
[Music]